today we have two stories about russian
prisons quite frankly um a number of you
wrote to me yesterday
and you sent me an article about a
teacher being imprisoned for political
speech in russia and said david is this
the woman who called into your show a
few months ago now i i've already looked
i don't believe it is the same woman
unless the woman who called in was
deliberately giving wrong information
about where she teaches and different
things but
it is a very cautionary tale about what
exactly was said by our caller and what
she feared because of her political view
so let me reset it for you
um article says russian teacher
sentenced for telling students about war
crimes in ukraine
this article is about irina genn
who received a five-year suspended
sentence and has been barred from
working in state schools and if you read
the article it says this is a school
teacher in a provincial provincial
russian city she got a suspended
sentence because she spoke out against
the kremlin's invasion of ukraine
and uh she was found guilty of
discrediting the russian armed forces
there's a new law that bans criticism of
the war in ukraine
and she got a five-year suspended
sentence and is barred from working in
state schools for three years the court
also found that she disseminated false
information
by telling students about the siege of
mariopol and russian airstrikes killing
children in ukraine
she was slapped with charges in march so
this was actually this predates our
caller but remember
the caller we had
who called in under a pseudonym
for exactly these types of fears listen
to this taking my questions so before
you go
you're calling from russia
yeah from moscow and so
what is the j would you say the general
sentiment there is that people like the
invasion of ukraine or people are
against the invasion of ukraine
uh i have to say that i will have a
certain moscow liberal bias because
that's the area where i was raised and
my family has always been uh critical of
the government uh there is not a single
person in my immediate uh circles that
are fans of this government okay but i
would say that just from my own personal
experience just looking at cars or
driving or parking anywhere i don't see
a single z
sign there is no single i would say
personal initiative to install anything
that is commemorative to this war
all i've seen is state council local
efforts which are sponsored from the
state from the federal budget to try and
convince people to engage in such
practices and some type of coercion
that's happening for example in
kindergartens oftentimes parents
discover that the school trip or the
kindergarten trip they send their
children to was actually a sort of
patriotic uh event
because they then later find pictures of
their children posed in the letter z on
social media or that's the patriotic
education trump keeps talking about now
listen do you feel safe expressing your
views antagonistic to the government
on here yes uh over at my university
i've already sort of spoken myself into
15 years of prison if anybody would like
deep
dig anywhere around me uh so um this is
just a weird stasis that i know that if
anybody looked at me or what i have been
writing what i've been saying it is
quite possible that i will face some
sort of fine or maybe even jail time
after all a person was arrested
yesterday for working out with a
printout of russian constitution onto
the streets
so
obviously not the same person our caller
called in may and we know that irene
again
was already under prosecution starting
in march so not the same caller but
these are not unfounded fears and
thankfully irene again has only received
a suspended sentence and can no longer
teach in state schools and will not be
imprisoned but these are real concerns
and this is what uh so many right
wingers are impressed with quite frankly
this is the type of they they find putin
to be incredibly strong it's sort of
like when duterte is strong because
he encourages the killing of drug
dealers it is a crazy world out there
and these authoritarians are actually
gaining support around the world
including from americans uh in the
united states in the american right wing
very scary stuff
the next story today about russian
prisons is that wnba star brittany
griner
has been sentenced to nine years in a
russian jail for drug smuggling now
remember the drug smuggling was under a
gram of cannabis oil
american women's basketball star
brittany griner was convicted of
deliberately smuggling drugs into russia
sentenced to nine years
in a case that is raising concerns that
she's being used as a political pawn in
russia's war against ukraine the judge
delivered the sentence and fined griner
a million rubles that's about sixteen
thousand dollars she said the court took
into account griner's partial admission
of guilt remorse state of health and
charitable activities
prior to the verdict greiner apologized
and asked for leniency quote i never
meant to hurt anybody i never meant to
put in jeopardy the russian population i
never meant to break any laws here i
made an honest mistake i hope that in
your ruling that it doesn't end my life
here i know everybody keeps talking
about political pawn and politics but i
hope that that is far from this
courtroom
i want to say again i had no intent on
breaking any russian laws i had no
intent i did not conspire or plan to
commit this crime she's been there six
months already
she is accused was accused of trying to
smuggle less than a gram of cannabis oil
in her luggage she pleaded guilty
and nine years now the u.s state
department is continuing to say that
this is a wrongful detention the biden
administration is continuing to
negotiate for her release and regardless
of what she says it has become an
explosive political situation now i want
to take a step further on this something
we mentioned on yesterday's bonus show
and i'm going to mention it again
there is a contingent of the
pro-authoritarian right-wing
that is reacting to progressives like me
saying
this is an example of the way the
russian justice system works 99
conviction rate outrageous sentences for
minor crimes all these different things
there's a group of right-wingers who
sort of likes authoritarianism and also
likes the war on drugs
that is saying you hypocritical
progressives you just want to criticize
putin and russia
and you don't say anything about the
fact that here in the united states we
also imprison people for cannabis don't
you care about that yes i do and i've
been talking about that for a decade the
fact that in the u.s we are i believe
unjustly imprisoning people for cannabis
possession
minimum we can go beyond possession as
well
um
that's not less of a problem because of
what's happening with brittany griner
russia is a different situation
where
the the entire picture of the judicial
system involves
everything from
uh
planted evidence prosecutions a decision
made a priori that this is someone we
need to imprison let's create charges
and the trial itself is a sham and of
course we have elements of that in the
united states but in the united states
the main problem
is
how we handle
drug possession and so-called drug
crimes and i'm against both so don't
come to me with this oh you're only
talking about it because it's an
opportunity to criticize russia
absolutely not we criticize it here in
the united states as well the dynamics
are different so now the hope becomes
a political solution i mean at this
point it doesn't seem as though the
solution is going to come from any other
place
let me know what you think you can find
me on twitter at d pacman but
extraordinarily disturbing news
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an independent
audience supported program you can sign
up for membership at joinpackman.com
we do a daily extra show for our members
called the bonus show we also offer a
commercial free audio and video feed of
the show for our members and it's
available way earlier than it is to
everybody else that's there's nothing
better than getting the show five hours
early at least that's what the kids
these days tell me
you can sign up at joinpackman.com
let's speak to people in the audience
last week's calls were fascinating some
of the better calls we've had
let's see if we can keep the streak
going we take calls via discord you can
find our discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord it's free completely and
totally free
let's start today
with jude from canada jude welcome
what's going on
hey david um i was just wondering uh
what you thought about canada's role in
the
ukraine
russia conflict and then i was also
wondering if you think canada will be
soon to follow with the us recession so
my understanding on in terms of canada's
involvement is
canada has provided
some training primarily and maybe some
arms to ukrainians and is it through
poland that they've done it i apologize
if i don't have all the facts in front
of me
yeah i believe that's it yeah i mean i
don't find anything particularly
shocking nor remarkable in the positive
or negative i mean it seems that
the vast majority of canadians
similarly interpret this as an
aggression act an invasion act by russia
they are
sympathetic to the ukrainian cause and i
mean is there something more specific
you wanted me to react to it seems sort
of like a normal response i guess i
would say
no that would that would be that would
be it i was more wondering about the
recession question i have no idea i mean
again i don't it's it really doesn't
seem to me that the us is in a recession
i know that there's this technical
when there's two consecutive quarters of
gdp shrinkage
we are in a recession but the last gdp
reduction from last quarter was so small
and when you look at the details it's a
result of decreased government spending
decreased inventories partially from
people buying so much stuff it's just
hard to look at that and being at nearly
full employment and the stock market
seemingly on the up and up at least over
the last half month or so and say this
is clearly a recession so never mind is
canada heading to a recession i don't
even know that the u.s is in one
okay interesting thank you
all right jude from canada thank you so
much for the call i appreciate it
why don't we speak next to
jill from burbank jill welcome
jill welcome to the program
hey uh
can you hear me david yes
okay perfect
uh i have a basically one question how
can we take seriously a party which is
the republican party yeah um that is pro
coup
pro
you know traders pro
anti-democrat you know anti-democrat
democracy
uh how can regular people take him
seriously and consider them as a
party like a major party well because we
have a very sick country i mean you're
you're pointing out something uh jill
which is
it's astute in its simplicity
in much of the world your average person
looks at the democratic party looks uh
and then and then looks at the
republican party
and says wait a second so the democrats
are i mean like i'll give you my opinion
the democrats are not nearly left enough
but here's a list of 15 things they want
to do that seem reasonable and they
generally support democracy and
whatever and then you look at the
republican party and it's trump's
winning primaries they're doing
everything from openly supporting
stealing an election that they didn't
win
all the way to you know
more minor but insane stuff like just
making fun of disabled reporters all of
it and in many countries people would
say there's really only one option there
you've got to vote for the democratic
party that republican stuff is crazy but
we have a very sick country here and we
have a lot of people who don't see it
that way and they seem to love the
republican party they seem to see it as
a as a legitimate participant in the
political system and so as i've said
many times before
crazy candidates and wild parties exist
in many parts of the world
but without millions of people to vote
for them they don't really go anywhere
and the us is so lucky that we have not
only the candidates but the people to
vote for them as well
but but i understand the crazy people
yeah we're we're actually not going to
consider the crazy people because you
know they always exist yeah this is
about irregular people
uh my question is specifically you know
uh
about them
how can the regular people of the united
states i know there is third thirty
percent of the united states that it's
crazy
uh but the rest are not
regular you know joe schmoe going to
work every day
not following any politics yeah but when
it comes to you know
every four years okay you know they get
a they get a mail-in ballot and they
fill it out
they do a little you know research
and find out hey i mean they also saw
what happened on on january 6th yeah how
can you think that and be like okay no
you know what i'm gonna go you know
republican party
that just does not make any sense to me
at all i'm i'm with you and i think that
so first of all remember
close to half the country doesn't vote
so first of all
half the country isn't even voting so we
can kind of eliminate them
of the half to 55 percent
that does vote
half of them vote for democrats instead
of republicans okay so now we're down to
like 25 of the country
of the 25 of the country that votes for
republicans you've got basically three
groups
the people that are just ignorant to the
facts and so we include we can include
in this both people who don't know
anything and also supposedly like the
crazy people the people that just have
no idea what's going on that's one group
then you have the bad people okay these
are people who they they see what's
going on and they want it they want to
discriminate they want to separate
children from family you know all these
different things and then you've got the
third group which is people who they
understand what's going on and they have
some selfish reason for voting for trump
anyway like they saw that he was crazy
but they thought he would lower their
taxes so so these are like the three
groups
so it's if you imagine that those groups
exist sort of evenly each group of those
is like eight percent of the country
that's a lot of people because the u.s
has such a large population but it's
actually not a huge percentage of the
country
jill
all right i guess jill's gone
let's go next to laura from summerville
laura welcome to the show
laura hello hello
hi how are you
i'm doing well how are you
pretty well
so i have a question
about the midterms please how much of an
impact do you think that aipac is going
to have when it comes to
the midterms and maybe you've already
covered this elsewhere
uh i don't know i mean i've not covered
it is
are they try are they having a
particular impact i've heard nothing
about aipac for years
laura
sorry
yeah can you hear me yeah
okay
so in terms of funding
towards campaigns that are
more
pro-palestinian mm-hmm
are there particular campaigns that
you're i don't know if i'm losing half
of what you're saying laura or if this
is the whole question i just is there a
particular race you're talking about i
mean it's there's so many different
packs and interest groups and they're
all
funding candidates and opposing can i
just don't know if there was like a
specific race or something in particular
that you had on your mind
i think
overall just across the country i've
been hearing that just from other
sources i didn't know if you
if you had an opinion on that no not i
just haven't heard that this particular
year that there's anything in particular
happening who are you hearing that from
laura
all right
thank you laura uh i don't know what was
going on there but very very strange
technical elements there surprising
let's go next to harry from columbus
ohio harry welcome
yes i can
thanks for taking my call now you don't
think that joe biden will run for
president in 2024 is that correct
that's that's it's just my guess yeah i
mean it's not like a prediction i just
don't think he's going to run no okay
split at 50 50. you think it's more
likely he will not run then he will run
yeah if you just give me even odds right
i mean i'm just saying i take the he
doesn't run side
can you briefly explain the reasons why
you think that is i know that you've
said that
kamala harris had to walk back a
statement where she said oh we're going
to run and she had to you know kind of
walk it back tomorrow sorry my bad um
yeah no that's not why
here's where i get that okay i just zoom
out a little bit
um
joe biden's almost 80 years old or is he
80 even i don't remember anyway he's
he's close to 80 or 80.
and i don't know that he ever really
intended to be president for eight years
from the get-go jensaki would say joe
biden intends to run which i know is not
a smoking gun in and of itself but it
was very very careful language the one
time someone went beyond that when
kamala said
he's running and i'm his running mate
within 24 hours she walked it back so i
i have to imagine there's some meaning
to walking it back
and quite frankly with the record low
approval dating all the way back to 1946
it's not clear he'd win i just don't
know
that 80 year old joe biden with a 37
percent approval is going to say what i
want to do right now is start another
presidential campaign two years from now
it's it's just you know different
reasonable people can disagree
yeah i agree and i think i'm not so
convinced that he's not going to run
just okay i don't think there's enough
evidence but i do see your point now i
just want to get into the more
substantive part of it is do you think
that is
why we know his approval is at you know
is lower less lower since you said since
the 40s since you said but presidential
uh incumbency win rates are i think 66
percent i think we've had
30 presidents run for re-election and
21. yeah um so i just don't know if it's
wise
to have somebody new and fresh i mean i
i know it's good content uh for yourself
to talk about potential candidates i'm
just worried about what will happen if
we bring in a limousine liberal like
gavin newsom yep um i'm i'm very scared
of somebody who isn't joe biden frankly
i think it's potentially scary either
way i mean when i think about biden
versus trump
uh biden is the incumbent and trump
hasn't even announced and those polls
are basically 50 50 already so if it's
biden trump again
i'm not confident biden wins
if it's desantis biden
i do think desantis being higher energy
and younger
will confer somewhat of an advantage and
i also don't think that that looks
particularly good for biden either so i
get what you're saying the power of
incumbency is significant we also may be
in a new political era where the where
incumbency is less powerful i mean trump
just lost and he was a one-term
president seeking re-election so i don't
know about that i think you're making
all valid points but i think there's
also another story to be told
i agree thanks for going over all that i
appreciate it have a great day my
pleasure thank you that's a that's a
powerful phone call uh very very strong
let's go
next where are we going next by the way
let's go to george from the uk george
welcome
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
hey yeah so um long time listener second
time caller um
so as you probably remember boris
johnson was um removed a few weeks ago
indeed the conservatives after months
and months of political pressure yep um
and a kind of turning point was reached
and a max mass exodus kind of occurred
and mass resignations and the government
could essentially no longer function
um
the actual scandal that broke the
camel's back
wasn't the worst boris johnson scandal
but it was kind of the cherry on the top
after you know months and months of just
awful behavior um
and a kind of additional data point here
before i get to my question is that the
conservatives have seen as very ruthless
and removing political leaders um i
don't know if you're aware of that but
it's kind of a reputation that they have
yes
um
and it got me thinking about trump and
how things in politics can move so
quickly
um things are kind of looking more and
more shaky for trump than ever as you've
covered fox news is laying the
groundwork to potentially support
another nominee
um and the republican establishment as
well is maybe looking for other you know
leaders so i was wondering if if
something happens like a charge from the
doj or something else like that do you
think something analogous could happen
to trump as it did with johnson so you
know the establishment suddenly turns
and goes all in on desantis or something
like that
will the you know will the republican
base
follow the establishment and
you know yeah and go all in or is this
situat situation just so different
and you know trump's personality cult of
personality is so strong
the debate you know the establishment
and or the base could never abandon him
i don't think we know the answer to that
yet i i don't i think it's going to be
it's not going to be one or the other so
let's let's just pick a number let's
imagine that trump's real base is
30 million people okay just to pick
something so that means that
that
of his votes what did he get 70 million
votes 60 something i forget the numbers
let's say he got 70 million votes in
2020.
30 million
are probably all but guaranteed
and then the other 40 million votes that
trump got are some combination of
reluctant republican supporters of trump
who just really don't like democrats
people who like trump's tax policy but
dislike other stuff
confused people you know i don't know
right so you start to like kind of slice
it up and then you have to say okay so
like if the rnc says trump's out
desantis is in
what does that do to these different
groups well he probably keeps most of
the 30 million trump does but then how
much of the 40 million does he keep and
then it's just really kind of a math
question and we just don't know where
that equation is gonna land
yeah i think so as well and i think it
also depends if if trump is eventually
kind of pushed out by the establishment
and it comes to a general election in 24
do those 30 million do they all
go okay well you know trump isn't on the
ticket so i might as well vote for
desantis right or do some become
disengaged again as they were pre-2016 i
think it's a combination i think there
are people who when trump is no longer a
shiny object that's interesting to them
on a ballot
they they uh
exit politics back to
where for where they came
and i just don't know how many i mean
we're talking about 30 million it's an
imaginary number i don't know how many
of the 30 million that applies to
yeah i guess we'll just wait and see
all right uh george thank you for the
call i appreciate it
thanks david all right we are going to
take the quickest of breaks but we're
going right back to the phones so there
are still plenty more opportunities to
chat with me just hold on if you're
holding and we will be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow let's
get back to the phones we take calls
every friday through the david pakman
show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com
discord
let's hear from folks like oh i don't
know
how about james from southern california
james
uh thank you very much can you hear me i
can hear you fine james
excellent um well first of all thank you
so much for everything you've done over
the years thank you i
wanted to ask your opinion on uh
something
what do you think the reality is of
us eliminating the electoral college
system and what would be the path to
that if it is a reality i see it as an
almost impossibility through
constitutional amendment this would be
one way to change the electoral college
it would be to actually have a
constitutional convention and and change
the way that it functions i see that as
almost an impossibility the more likely
scenario is something called the
national popular vote interstate compact
the way this works is
individual states can decide they can de
decide to assign their electoral votes
however they want
normally what states do is they say
whoever wins our state gets the
electoral votes but states can say
instead we're going to give our
electoral votes to whoever wins the
national popular vote so you could have
a state like for example pennsylvania
say
in the future
we're not going to pay attention to
whether trump or biden win pennsylvania
we're going to pay attention to whether
trump or biden get more votes nationally
and that's who will get pennsylvania's
electoral votes does that part make
sense james how that would work
yes it does uh so it sounds like
pretty much if we want to achieve this
we'd have to start rallying on the state
level and the thing is a bunch of states
have already signed up for this and of
course for it to go into force
you need enough states to do it
such that their electoral votes would be
more than the 270 that one needs to
become president but the problem is
we're getting we've got a lot of the
blue states some red states or at least
purple states are going to need to come
aboard and so that's the that's the
challenge right now but i see that as a
way more likely way to get to a national
popular vote than a constitutional
amendment
sounds good at least there's some
reality they're pulling it off yeah yeah
it's not an impossibility but it's also
you know this is not everyone's top
priority i think it's fair to say yeah
and that's that's the problem it's a
long shot people aren't pushing for it
we've got all these important short-term
things to deal with exactly that just
falls by the wayside well thank you so
much for your time david i appreciate it
all right my pleasure there is james
from southern california
making a number of important
declarations
let's go next to preston from maryland
preston welcome to the program
hello can you hear me i can preston you
you have not called in before have you
uh i actually did call in once a while
ago during a trump rally oh okay well my
brain was so turned to mush i couldn't
even
think of a question your brain was
mayonnaise from the rally and you had to
hang up on it
all right good
yeah
so um so what what can we do as the
american people to kind of counter
the left right red team versus blue team
sort of tribalism that just keeps
getting worse and worse every year it
seems
oh well see the problem with that
question is i
you know there's there's a couple how do
i even want to approach this
i think that the degree of tribalism
that we have in the united states is a
problem there are people who will just
support or oppose
ideas
based on the letter next to someone's
name whether it's an r or a d i think
that a lot of these things are bad the
concern is
a lot of the people talking about
tribalism these days
want to sort of portray themselves as
the enlightened centrists who are above
partisan politics and fairly evaluate
every issue and all these different
things and want to find some kind of
middle ground when there really is no
reasonable middle ground on so many
issues there's no middle ground between
climate change is real based on the
science and climate change is imaginary
well so it's kind of real well that
that's crazy and so my concern is i'm
not saying this about you necessarily
preston but sometimes when people when
they they just say tribalism's really
the issue
there's a little bit of this both sides
and light and centrism stuff going on
where some of these people are nuts
there's no working with them they just
we need to figure out a way to get them
out of politics
yeah i can understand that
all right
yeah can you can you hear me i can hear
you fine preston
no
oh yeah yes so
yeah that's that's a pretty
good point i don't really have any
follow
i'm sorry
all right very good preston we're losing
you so i'm gonna let you go preston very
interesting topic and uh we've talked a
lot about this enlightened centrism
thing and it's quite a quite a situation
let's go next to ed
from
new hampshire ed welcome are you living
free or dying up there or what
i am living free uh mr pacman thank you
um let me just say thank you for having
me on here as a first time caller my
pleasure and i wanted to talk about um
firearms laws because i'm someone who
is a fairly pro-gun person but at the
same time
i really really hate the republican
party i grew up in a family that
had people growing up within the
homosexual community and i'm sorry but
you know i grew up in a time when the
republican party still does
actively oppress homosexuals and i can't
put myself support myself behind that
party okay now wait hold on when you say
you you grew up in a homosexual
community what does that mean
not a community i mean like a family
like i have a gay cousin oh i got i got
it okay okay okay
all right so but at the same time you
know
i i would i have a hard time voting for
the democrats because of
some of the things they they put forward
regarding gun control law okay and i'm
someone who believes that
there are some compromises both sides
can make but i actually believe that
a lot of the proposals democrats are
making
isn't pro isn't a good way to
go across this and it's not going to
actually
make these
shootings um stop i actually think in
some cases it may actually make them
worse all right well let's dig into that
first of all when i talk about gun
violence when i talk about quote
shootings
i think there are three different types
of shootings and each has to be dealt
with separately so there's
firearms suicides
there's individual firearms homicides uh
individual firearms homicides and then
you've got your mass shootings am i
correct that today you want to talk
about the mass shootings right you're
not talking right now about gun suicides
or the individual
homicides um no well yeah let's uh talk
about the mass shootings because i do
because i because if there's one thing i
hate about the right it's the whole
suicide mentality thing is that that is
one side about the pro gun control the
um pro gun side that i absolutely
deserve we want to reduce all three of
these types of deaths but right the
solutions are different you and i are
going to talk about the mass shootings
give me an example of something
democrats want to do that you think
might actually make mass shootings worse
um for example banning the ar-15 and
when i say this it's because of it has
nothing to do with
the a with like the magazine capacity or
anything else it's that
there the chances are is that the ar-15
believe believe it or not
is not all that high-powered of a rifle
there are a lot of other high-powered
rifles out there
in america that mimic everything the
ar-15 does okay let me stop you there
because i think this one we might be
very easily able to resolve
the proposal i'm currently seeing would
ban all assault style rifles ar-15 being
only one of them if we said assault
style rifles instead of just the ar-15
would that deal with the fact that there
are ar-15 alternatives
uh no it's because there are plenty of
other rifles out there that function
exactly the same way as the ar-15 but
are significantly older they we're
talking about weapons that date back to
the world war eras
and i just you know these are weapons
that have been out there in civilian
hands for decades right but the number
of the world war one world war ii era
guns that you're thinking of are number
one not being actively manufactured
today and number two not nearly as
widely available just by the sheer math
right oh oh no that is actually not true
there are millions and millions of world
war ii firearms out there still being is
still them some of them even still being
made today um one of them being the m1
carbine
oh so you're not literally okay so yeah
now i'm getting you're you're saying
you're not literally saying units that
have been around for 80 years you're
saying models that are being
manufactured today but have been around
a long time
yes the same thing is true for the ar-15
itself the ar-15 has been in civilian
circulation since the 60s
right but i don't know that the fact
that these
have been around for a while means
anything one way or the other i'm not
sure what what what's the point of that
what difference does that make
well the thing is is that this mass
shooting trend you know the way it's
been happening all around yeah it's a
fairly recent trend you know i mean this
isn't to say that shootings like uh
didn't happen in the 60s i mean we all
know charles women and everything like
that
however at the rate at where they're
occurring nowadays yep and uh you know
the certain definitions that uh the gva
um portrays as what is a mass shooting
which i think can be
is a little problematic in it of itself
because
um okay but hold on now you're on to it
now you're talking about how you
categorize we're all over the place
let's let's let's see if i can reign
this in okay
yeah i'm sorry about that when it comes
to
the guns
i'm with you that something has changed
in american culture right there's a
cultural issue where more people than
ever
see guns as a way to solve
grievances that they have either with
individuals or with society that's new
and i completely agree with you
but i also believe that
if at this point in time
americans are less able than ever to
behave responsibly with firearms at a
population level
that still means we've got to do
something about the guns just
even if we grant that something about
the culture has changed where now we
have so many more people willing to do
gun violence i would still want to deal
with the guns and all of the other
things as well i would take an all of
the above approach is that fair
it is fair yes um the problem again the
uh
and i love having this conversation with
you let me just say that right now
because
this is something that a lot of people
uh on the right a lot of pro-gun people
don't do and this is something that i'm
trying to champion you know sure i hang
around with a lot of pro-gun people and
i try to get them to talk to
progressive people because believe it or
not there are a lot more progressive gun
owners out there than people may oh
there are there are yeah and and listen
it's reasonable to me not to want only
the right wing nuts to have the guns i
mean that makes sense so let me just say
this because we don't have unlimited
time
i am with you
no one provision will solve all the
problems right like if you just say
banning the ar-15 won't solve the mass
shooting problem i'm with you that won't
solve the mass shooting problem um
restricting access to high-capacity
magazines alone won't solve the mass
shooting problem because someone can get
grab four handguns or whatever and go
okay so i'm with you 100
my approach and i laid i don't want to
do it now because i've done it so many
times i laid out a 10 or 12 point list
of all the things that i would do on the
gun side and that doesn't mean we don't
do mental health and all we do
everything but i have 10 to 12 different
things i would do which i believe
together
would dramatically reduce mass shootings
i i have seen those points and the one
point and most of the points i do agree
on oh the one point i have a problem on
is when you say banning some guns
and that is the one area where i
have i'm very hesitant about because
should the average person be allowed to
have a shoulder-mounted rpg
well people do have rpgs okay i know
people that do i i'm not saying that
anecdotally you don't know but as a
general thing
should an uh shoulder mounted rpg be as
widely available as a handgun
i i would say so yes okay how about a
how about a blackhawk helicopter
a blackhawk helicopter hell yeah i would
love to have one of those okay how about
a howitzer how about a howitzer should
anyone be able to go and get a howitzer
i know people that have howitzers yes
okay but that's not the question should
anyone go and be able to get a howitzer
well they can though that's the thing no
they can't you can't go i mean listen
i'm not saying you might not be able to
somehow obtain one but a howitzer is not
something you can just go to a gun store
and order
well well that well that is true right
so what and is that okay is that okay
that you can i mean is your is your
right to have whatever gun you want
being restricted by the fact that you
can't go to a gun store in new hampshire
and get a howitzer
well that well that is the problem that
i'm asking you is um is not so much
whether or not it should be like
available for every gun store it's just
the fact whether or not they should be
legally allowed to buy but what i'm
asking you is
should
you be able to go to a gun store
and say hi one howitzer please do you
believe that should be the law
depending on the type of store
i mean
i'm talking about the person buying it
should any person be able to own a
howitzer
any any person based off of the way the
second amendment is written
yeah
of course that's crazy i've never i
honestly i've never heard anyone argue
that before even ben shapiro didn't
argue that
it's uh it's a very weird the laws in
this country the reason i say this is
because i know people that legally have
bought these things
and they are just private citizens okay
so i don't i'm not aware of that so i i
can't really speak to it but i'm gonna
have to research that but ed listen i
gotta run i really appreciate the
conversation
oh this is that definitely i mean i'd
love to talk more with you but my uh
headset is actually running low on
battery so great top great timing thanks
all right ed go recharge your bluetooth
that interesting conversation i mean
anyone can just go get a howitzer and a
blackhawk helicopter that that's crazy
even the most
you know fervent
uh gun people i've not heard say that
all right everybody that's it for today
we will take calls again let's take a
very short break
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the mailbag
info davidpakman.com info
davidpakman.com
info
davidpakman.com keep them polite keep
them quick keep them substantive
and maybe it'll make the show
or some people try other approaches
let's start with our first email today
from
cune i think it's pronounced
trump your podcast
i wonder if you would be so kind as to
tell me who in the democratic party is
paying and how much
nobody from the democratic party is
paying me anything
george soros is not paying anything
the uh
klaus schwab is not paying any none of
them are paying anything
we exist
thanks to our audience our viewers
through a number of revenue sources
including uh membership
and youtube ads facebook ads you know
these types of things all right so
whoever you think is paying us
they are not unless you're talking about
our audience but thank you for asking
rebecca rhoden
rebecca says please take down your video
biden making fun of trump for
covid19s
experience
ps
you can't trump fat
you are not fat and only fat people can
call other people fat
then it's okay skinny man please don't
show my email address thank you call me
mona well listen it's not about me
calling people fat
it's about
trump is obviously lying about his
height and weight
and when we think about your ability to
deal with
something like covid
one's weight and condition
is a big factor in determining
you know what is going to be a more less
likely outcome
and um donald trump is obese i mean it's
not it's not a pejorative he's just
obese it's all it is all right rebecca
mona we are not taking the video down
the video is staying up thank you very
much we will manage the youtube channel
as we see fit
teresa from san francisco wrote in with
a question about anthony fauci teresa
says hi david you mentioned recently
that elements in the republican party
are gearing up to investigate dr fauci's
handling of the pandemic if they retake
the house and or senate in the midterms
if this happens
do you think it would be possible for
president biden to pardon dr fauci
preemptively or otherwise listen the
answer is yes there's two issues here
that i think about when i hear oh just
pardon fouchy preemptively to protect
him okay number one
republicans will go
nuts absolutely nuts they will treat it
as if trump had preemptively pardoned
don jr even though the circumstances
would be completely different don jr may
genuinely have been involved in crimes
dr fauci is a public health official who
conspiracy theorists and extremists have
created a vendetta against so one is
republicans would go so crazy who knows
what would happen and number two
it would be a really really sad
commentary on the state of the country
and we know the state of the country is
in the toilet but it would be a really
sad commentary on the state of the
country
for a president
to have to preemptively pardon
a career public health official who's
over 80 and is retiring because of
uh
the the rabid
attackers from the american right it
would just be such a sad situation but
yeah i mean biden could do it i hope it
really doesn't come to that
todd wrote in about trump rallies todd
asks have you noticed it's the same
black guy in the background of all trump
rallies i only watch snip it's i like
that that's beautiful uh snippets of his
rallies when replayed on shows like
yours and i've seen the same guy in the
background at all his rallies meaning
that guy is traveling to all his rallies
being paid to attend so there's two
different things going on
i know the guy that todd is talking
about
i think that that guy is part of the
group blacks for trump
and um
it's everything about it is very unclear
we just we don't know about it we don't
want to offend anybody we don't want to
dismiss anyone's activism or anything
but there's something very odd about the
entire blacks for trump group they have
almost no presence online except for one
website which is just
very strange rants we don't really know
what to make of it it's all very very
weird
but that's one thing
separate from that is the reality that
like many republicans republicans have
very low support from from black
americans
republicans
love
to put the black folks right on the
stage behind them to make the crowd
appear more diverse than it actually is
so it wouldn't be
shocking
if absent a natural black crowd
the trump campaign the trump people had
some
friends of the campaign of friends of
trump who they would fly around so they
would have black people on the stage
it's mere speculation i want to be clear
i'm not saying that's going on
i'm just saying it wouldn't
really surprise me
next email is from sean about republican
indoctrination
sean says sir if you want to see some
truly disturbing republican
indoctrination
look at prageru kids it pisses me off
that the american right claims that
schools are brainwashing our kids to be
communists
when they talk about how they want
patriotic education
give me a break
sincerely
sean from minnesota 100
they say now um they are quote teaching
transgender to our kids to indoctrinate
them they are pushing puberty blockers
on kids much too young to even be near
puberty why would they do that doesn't
make sense they are
pushing kids to be gay they are pushing
kids to be trans college is liberal
indoctrination they are making them
communists they're making them
socialists they're making all this
different stuff
we would never do that and then you look
at the
learning about trump for kids stuff that
mike huckabee promotes you look at
prageru kids
you look at all of the different ways
that they want churches indoctrinating
kids not just into a religious doctrine
most churches indoctrinate kids into
religious doctrine
but they want the church's
indoctrinating kids into a political
doctrine as well for which by the way
they should lose their nonprofit status
but they almost never do
100 percent correct sean that is exactly
what they are doing
dylan wrote in dylan says could the big
lie reduce voter turnout do you think
the big lie could reduce voter turnout
among those who believe it
trumpists who think the 2020 election
was stolen
may not see any point in voting and may
not want to go out of their way to vote
interested to hear your thoughts
100
in fact
last week marjorie taylor green said
this marjorie taylor green last week
said she's worried
that the trump people
may not be that enthusiastic about
coming up to out to vote in november and
then she parroted the big lie
which is one of the reasons that
republicans sometimes don't come out to
vote the anecdote i mentioned last week
was the january 5 special election
senate elections in georgia remember
there were these two runoffs january 5
2021 and because trump and republicans
spent the two-month period between the
november election and the january
special elections basically just saying
it was all stolen
um
that almost certainly reduced turnout in
january
and arguably cost republicans control of
the senate that's what's crazy they
don't even seem to fully understand it's
your narrative about the big lie that is
causing these problems for you to begin
with i hope they keep doing it i mean it
just hurts them
natalie wrote in about ar-15s david did
you see where they now have a new gun
the junior 15 the jr15 market it to kids
we are in serious trouble but you knew
this love the show i did see the junior
15. um
it is
insane it is it's quite literally a
rifle marketed to children
it is uh the graphics on the i mean
everything about it is uh indicative of
an extraordinarily sick country
i i really don't know what else to say
about it it's
we just have special rifles marketed to
children here
it i i'm i'm without any further words
to say
dominic from the uk wrote in and says hi
david whilst you and i understand trump
couldn't get reelected without the
backing of the republican party do you
think his low intellect coupled with his
high ego could convince him to run as an
independent if he fails to get the
republican nomination thus ensuring a
democrat victory in 2024 i think this is
a beautiful strategy the ideal scenario
for the left would be
trump runs for the nomination of the
republican party but loses someone else
wins you know right now desantis is the
lead guy
someone else wins
trump
furious
decides to run
as an independent
he siphons off
20 of the republican vote and ensures
that the democratic candidate
cruises to victory i think it would be
absolutely fantastic he should be
encouraged to do so
i do think speaking realistically
that if trump lost the republican
nomination in 2024 his kids would be
able to talk him out of running as an
independent i think they'd say dad
don't do this to yourself
you had a good run you're almost 80.
screw him let's go and do something else
i do think his kids would be able to
talk him out of it
bobby wrote in
with an answer to what is a woman
that he says would shut down
conservatives
bobby writes david i keep hearing this
question and my mind is boggled that
neither you katanji brown jackson nor
any single sitting democrat or spokesman
for the lgbtq community has given this
simple response i majored in poli sci
and i'm a freelance writer next time
you're asked or please tell your
audience here is your response
all words have multiple definitions and
to quote the oxford dictionary
traditionally the preeminent dictionary
on the planet
the definition of a woman is a person
with the qualities traditionally
associated with females this definition
100 describes transgender women and i've
never heard a single democrat use it
this would shut up anyone that asks
sorry robert it's almost
quaint that you think that would be like
a whoa mic drop moment if you say to
them a person with the qualities
traditionally associated with females
they would go
like a vagina
and you just are opening up a whole new
can of worms in a whole discussion
i used to have these ideas like robert i
would go
this is so dumb
here's the incontrovertible
mic drop hammer of an answer that'll
have them on their knees quivering
unable to respond
and then i'd realize wait a second they
always have a response that's not how
politics works if you if you use this
definition a woman is a person with the
qualities traditionally associated with
females they would go females have
particular genitalia
boom it's over
i'm not telling you that their question
what is a woman is isn't bad faith i'm
not saying any of that
i'm just saying
trust me that is not going to have
the
powerful impact
that you think it will
info davidpakman.com get your thoughts
in questions comments ideas suggestions
and we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad such a good bonus show
that i won't even tell you what's on it
sign up at jointpakman.com